DIRE STATE:
Once upon a time, Panasonic was one of the
largest electronics brands in the world making
everything from TVs and appliances to batteries
and phones.
They were the pride of Japan alongside Sony
and Toshiba throughout the mid to late 1900s
as they recovered for the devastating ruins
of World War 2.
But, the 2000s haven’t been so nice to Panasonic.
They’ve shut down their communications business,
much of their TV business, and even their
LCD business.
They’ve been forced to sell off many of
their assets including their security business,
their semiconductor business, and most notably
their entire $3.5 billion stake in Tesla.
Things haven’t been looking much better
internally either.
Panasonic’s revenue has fallen by over 40%,
their gross profit has nearly halved, and
they’ve written off tens of billions of
dollars worth of losses.
As such, their employee count has shrunk by
over a hundred thousand people within the
past 13 years.
Honestly, the only thing at Panasonic that
hasn’t gone straight down is ironically
their stock price.
But this isn’t all that much better anyway
as the stock has basically just been going
sideways for the past 30 years.
And, when you account for inflation, you’ll
see that Panasonic stock is actually down
66% over the past 30 years.
Seeing all this, I decided to check the bankruptcy
probability for Panasonic.
Usually for big tech companies, the probability
is less than 1%.
For more distressed companies like GoPro,
the number is usually in the low double digits.
So, with that in mind, do you wanna guess
how much it is for Panasonic?
Maybe 70 or 80%?
Well, it’s straight up over 100%.
This is something that I’ve never seen before.
So, odds are that unless a miracle happens
or the Japanese government steps, someone
who’s already drowning in debt, Panasonic
is as good as dead.
But what happened?
As far as I can remember, there was never
really any pivotal moment for the company.
They kind of just slowly lost steam over the
course of decades right?
Well, there’s actually a lot more to the
story as much of Panasonic’s demise can
be attributed to them forgetting about their
roots.
So, join me as take a look back at the rise
and fall of Panasonic and try to pinpoint
what went wrong.
ALWAYS KEEP EXPERIMENTING:
Panasonic's fall from grace shows how even
major corporations can falter when they lose
sight of their core strengths.
This iconic Japanese brand went from electronics
giant to borderline bankruptcy by failing
to adapt to changing technologies and markets.
Now, everyday investors face their own challenges
finding stable returns amidst economic uncertainty.
Just last week, the Federal Reserve opted
to pause rates leaving us with historic high
interest rates of 5.25%.
Investing in bonds now means locking in high
rates before the Federal Reserve starts decreasing
them once again.
Companies and legendary investors are well
aware of this and that’s why they’ve been
investing hundreds of billions into bonds
over the past year.
If you’d like to leverage these high interest
rates for yourself, that’s where Silo, our
upcoming bond investing platform comes into
play.
With Silo, you can not only invest in treasuries,
but you can also invest in bonds issued by
corporations such as Apple, Nike, or Coca-Cola
all with no markups and $500,000 in SIPC insurance
and $2.5 million in FDIC insurance.
If that sounds worthwhile, please consider
checking out Silo in the description below.
But anyway, taking a look back, the story
of Panasonic dates back to November 27, 1894
to a man named Konosuke Matsushita.
Konosuke was born to a poor rice farming family
and was the youngest of 5 daughters and 3
sons.
By the time that Konosuke was just 4 years
old, his father would end up losing their
entire family farm as he speculated on the
rice exchange.
Having lost everything, Konosuke’s father
would head to the city to find a job but that
wasn’t enough.
Pretty soon, young Konosuke himself would
have to start working at just age 9.
He would start off at a Hibachi store before
moving on to a Bicycle store, but while the
circumstances weren’t that great, these
jobs taught Konosuke a great deal about the
business world.
How to attract customers, how to keep them
happy, how to keep employees loyal, and most
importantly, how to walk away with a modest
profit.
During these long days of work, Konosuke would
start seeing streetcars pop up across Osaka
and this would convince him that the future
of business had to do with electricity.
So, at age 15, he decided to leave his gig
at the bicycle shop and join the Osaka Electric
Light Company.
As a natural hard worker, Konosuke would rapidly
rise up the ranks and become an inspector
by the time that he was just 22 years old.
It’s crazy to think that he already had
13 years of work experience, 7 of which were
in the electrical business by the time that
he was just 22.
All of this hard work had allowed Konosuke
to escape the depths of poverty but Konosuke
had far larger ambitions and this is when
he was start budding heads with management.
In his early 20s for example, he would design
an improved light socked and pitch it to his
supervisor.
But his supervisor would simply dismiss the
idea claiming that it was useless and would
go nowhere.
Invigorated by these remarks, Konosuke would
decide to quit his job and try his hand at
business.
And with that, he would set up shop inside
his tiny 2 room apartment with his wife and
brother in law in June of 1917.
If this was a Dhar Mann video, Konosuke’s
new light socket would end up going viral
and he would end up buying out his old employer
and stick to to his old supervisor.
But unfortunately, it’s not and unfortunately,
Konosuke’s light socket didn’t go anywhere
anywhere.
In fact, things were so bad that he would
have to sell the few valuables that he had
just to get by.
Unwilling to quit though, Konosuke continued
experimenting and creating new products and
after several months he would finally land
on a product that someone actually wanted:
insulation plates for fans.
This product gave him enough money to sustain
himself leading to the Matsushita Electric
aka Panasonic on March 7, 1918.
But while things were going decently well
with the insulation plates, Konosuke still
didn’t have to heart to just give up on
the light sockets.
So, he would revisit and redesign his socket
leading to the creation of 2 new products:
an attachment plug and a two way socket.
Unlike Konosuke’s original light socket,
these new sockets would gain steam almost
immediately which brings us into Konosuke’s
first principle: always keep experimenting.
Even if your first idea doesn’t work, it’s
more than likely that some iteration of it
would.
In fact, Konosuke felt so strongly about this
that he would keep a pencil and paper by his
bedside.
This way, if he got any new ideas in his sleep,
he could jot them down and put them to work.
Anyway, the momentum of this new socket allowed
Konosuke to move his operation to a larger
two story house and scale his workforce to
20 employees, marking the beginning of Panasonic’s
monumental run.
GREAT PRODUCTS DON’T SELL THEMSELVES:
Moving into the 1920s, things were going much
better.
Panasonic had turned into a legitimate local
business but that isn’t to say that the
road ahead was always smooth.
In fact, Konosuke would find himself in another
difficult situation with his next product
itself.
What hurt the most with this product was that
going into it, Konosuke was sure that it was
gonna be a banger.
It was one of those ideas that he got while
sleeping and woke up thinking: Eureka!
What was this product you ask?
Well, it was a simple bicycle light.
Battery powered lights were already a thing
but they were completely impractical as they
only lasted 2 to 3 hours.
So most people, including Konosuke himself
resorted to using a candle lamp when biking.
Frustrated by this reality, Konosuke would
spend 6 months designing a bullet shaped bicycle
lamp that was truly revolutionary lasting
30 to 40 hours.
Excited, Konosuke would strike deals with
a bunch of wholesalers and stock stores all
throughout the city but to his utter disappointment,
not a soul would buy these lamps.
Why you ask?
Well, because people had already made up their
mind that battery powered lamps sucked.
Konosuke kept holding out hope that the strength
of product would shine through in this overlooked
market but it never happened.
To make things worse, the Great Kanto Earthquake
would strike in September of 1923 which destroyed
much of his sales partners.
But by now, I think you know that Konosuke
never quits. 4 years later, he would come
back to the bicycle lamp market with a square
shaped lamp.
Nothing much had changed internally, but Konosuke’s
approach to selling these lamps was completely
different.
For starters, the light was an odd square
shape, something that people had never seen
before.
This was very much on purpose.
It was to emphasize that this light itself
was nothing like people had seen before.
Konosuke also bought out newspaper ads that
read "National Lamps: Buy for Your Assurance,
Use for Your Benefit."
And to round it all off, Konosuke would hand
out 10,000 samples to stores without any sort
of obligation.
The result?
Well, Konosuke would end up selling 30,000
units per month by the end of the first year
itself which brings us into Konosuke’s second
principle: good products don’t sell themselves.
Just because you have a good product doesn’t
mean that people will line up outside your
door wanting to buy.
Even a good product requires an even better
marketing campaign.
Having realized this with the bicycle lamp,
Konosuke would vow to never let marketing
screw over a good product.
And with that, he would completely restructure
the company in 1929.
He would create 4 succinct divisions, one
for each of their major product categories:
electrical sockets, batteries, bicycle lamps,
and radios.
Each of these divisions had their own national
sales department with regional departments
underneath them.
And to top it off, Konosuke would directly
link the sales departments with their respective
manufacturing departments.
This way, manufacturing was directly dependent
on sales, reducing the likelihood of over
or underproduction.
With this brand new salesforce in place, Panasonic
would enter the 1930s with pure dominance
as they grew to be a national player employing
over 10,000 people.
But, just as Panasonic was hitting a stride,
WW2 would roll around.
DOWNTURNS ARE A BLESSING:
There’s really on easy way to put it, WW2
destroyed Panasonic.
Throughout the war, Panasonic struggled to
get materials and hire talent as young men
were being recruited to the war.
To make things worse, the company was forced
to focus on industrial production efforts
for the war.
Konosuke was hopeful that things would get
better after the war but they only got worse
as I think we all know how the war came to
an end.
Japan was literally bombed into oblivion which
not only destroyed everything that Konosuke
had built but what the entire country had
built.
Just when you thought things couldn’t get
any worse, General Douglas MacArthur and the
Americans would begin occupying the country
and basically take control.
And one of their reform orders was for Konosuke
to step down and relinquish control of Panasonic.
Konosuke didn’t even resist but you know
who did?
His 15,000 employees who signed a petition
to keep Konsuke in power.
They argued that Konosuke was a virtal part
of their reconstruction effort and that removing
him would basically destroy the company.
Fortunately for Panasonic, Konosuke’s resignation
order would end up getting rescinded allowing
Konosuke to continue leading the company.
But, while Konosuke had somehow managed to
keep control of his company, he had lost all
momentum.
Any normal person would’ve been distraught
beyond belief but Konosuke was never the pessimistic
type.
In fact, he was rather optimistic which brings
us into his 3rd core business principle.
Good times are good and bad times are even
better.
You see, Konosuke believes that downturns
are the perfect time to evaluate the state
of a business and reinvent it.
When things are going well, you’re usually
scared to do something different and screw
up what you already have.
But, when things are going bad, well you’ve
got nothing left to lose so might as well
take a risk and see if that unlocks a whole
new level.
And that’s exactly what Konosuke would do.
He would tell his employees to approach the
business with the attitude that they had just
opened which wasn’t far from the truth given
that Panasonic would start targetting a completely
different market: the global market.
To be honest, Panasonic had no other choice
given that the Japanese economy was in no
state to support so many employees by themselves.
So, the entire 1950s was focused on launching
western products.
This included Washing Machines, TVs, refrigerators,
radios, portable radios, rice cookers, tape
recorders, and ACs.
This was also around the time that the name
Panasonic actually came about.
Given the new international focus, they needed
an easy English name and they would settle
on Panasonic.
Pan means universal and Sonic means sound,
so “Panasonic” was supposed to signify
the company bringing the sound of Japan to
the entire world.
And this marked the beginning of Panasonic’s
golden era: the 60s, 70s, and 80s but as we
now know, this golden era wouldn’t last
forever.
THE BRUTAL FALL:
It’s sad to say but Panasonic’s peak basically
aligns exactly with Konosuke’s death in
1989.
Eversince Konosuke died, it has only been
downhill for Panasonic and it’s no wonder
why.
They basically completely forgot about the
principles that made the business successful
in the first place.
Take Konosuke’s principle of always keep
experimenting for example.
Well, after Konosuke’s death, Panasonic
completely stopped experimenting and if you
don’t wanna believe me just take it from
Panasonic’s website itself.
Here’s all the products they launched in
the 50s.
the 60s and 70s.
Here’s all the products they launched in
the 80s and even 90s.
And here’s all the products they launched
in the 2000s.
Yeah, you’re not looking at that wrong,
there’s not even a single product listed
on there.
Their last notable product was way back in
98 when they launched digital TVs for the
US.
You can only hit the ball out of the park
if you try swinging.
Panasonic has not swung in 25 years.
But not only has Panasonic shied away from
new products but they’ve also dropped the
ball on their existing product lines.
You know how we talked about how there was
no pivotal moment for Panasonic.
It wasn’t like their products just suddenly
sucked or their pricing went through the roof
or anything like that.
The reality is that Panasonic products are
still quite great.
But, the thing to keep in mind is that great
products don’t sell themselves, and this
is perfectly exemplified by Samsung.
Samsung ranks lower than Panasonic across
the board when it comes to product quality,
pricing, and customer service but Samsung
is worth over 10 times Panasonic.
You know why?
Because Samsung knows how to market their
products whether it’s appliances, TVs, or
smartphones.
Seriously, when was the last time you saw
a Panasonic ad?
I bet the answer is too long ago to remember.
Now, when was the last time you saw a Samsung
ad?
I bet the answer is too recently to remember.
Basically anytime you’re browsing the web
or watching a video or shopping or driving,
you probably saw Samsung branding.
But you probably don’t even remember because
you’re so desensitized to it.
With this sort of marketing discrepancy, it’s
no wonder why people choose Samsung or LG
when buying a new TV or new appliances.
Good products don’t sell themselves.
Panasonic’s competitors understand this,
Panasonic doesn’t.
Something else that Panasonic doesn’t seem
to understand is that downturns can be a blessing.
Back in the 40s, Panasonic had lost basically
everything but they were able to make it work
by not losing hope and shifting gears.
The early 2000s would’ve been the perfect
time to do this again.
Imagine if they were the first person to jump
onto the smartphone trend instead of Samsung
or if they were the ones to capitlize on OLED
technology.
They could’ve made a name for themselves
in the modern tech era.
But instead, it seems that Panasonic has lost
hope which is likely the most disappointing
part of all of this.
Whether it was the failed light socket or
the bicycle lamp or WW2, one thing that remained
constant was Konosuke’s optimism for the
future.
Modern Panasonic on the other hand seems to
have lost all hope.
They’re not experimenting, marketing or
leveraging the downturn.
It almost seems like they’ve already accepted
defeat and are just trying to hold on for
as long as possible and with this sort of
mindset, it’s no wonder why the writing
is on the wall for their bankruptcy.
Another legacy giant that’s actually managing
make a turnaround is Nokia.
Check out this video to learn more.